ciao a tutti ragazzi benvenuti questo
video sono pochi geni la prima volta che
siamo solo prostrato sul mio canale e
sono con stef era hanno fatto fusi orde
di mi diceva sempre che ancora più figo
fatto su robot quindi niente siamo qua
facciamo st mega partita spacchiamo cdv
your daddy
gli spiego come funziona ok alla busi
verdetti sarebbe una modalità di gioco
dove uno fa il papa e gli altri due
fanno i bambini i bambini devono cercare
di suicidarsi nel mentre che il papa
tenta di prenderli e di evitare che
facciano perché di salvarli
facciamoci sentito gli hunger games dove
tutti i bambini e si deve per evitare
che i bambini che si pensa il geniale
dovrete fare è parente del bambino io
bambino l'inizio accusano anche un
bambino quindi fare come si salta in
tutto questo saltando ok vado vado vado
vado
allora questa e faccia fare ma come loro
mi capita con quella sarebbe il papa
guarda il colore di questo è diventato
perché mi ha preso a schiaffi vedi che
sono stati sei in grigio ok da fare per
cortesia per gli esperti step per favore
civili insieme cosa vuoi da me questo
vale per e smettila volete fare stare
siamo in giro a due bambini in giro
perché anche a tranquilli c'è bambini
brutti sembriamo un rossi non magione
non sembrate degli ovetti degli ovetti
esatte gli eletti si fa sotto segreto ma
è vero mi ero dimenticato di lei perde
alta da qui non mi ricordo dove finiamo
a te lo dico mai ciao
ma mazzarri sta dietro i numeri ma come
poco o affatto arrivarci in forza
accucciare ricavi aggregati con cisco ed
amica vi fregate questo non possiamo
aprire la mente questo possiamo aprire
la via sono lenti ma io sono trovati a
gola col martello si mi sta picchiando
avessero ci pensate voi se devo pensare
io mi viene che le cose cambino il mouse
in b col tasto destro
ciao stavo click qui anni va in piscina
o in piscina la cia non diedi dove siani
allora
tutto il giorno vi verrà ma perché
chiudete le porte pensare a lui come
scuro
se si divide la pallina teoricamente la
segue però se va in acqua potrebbe
essere un problema cane non affogare
stata io a utah avevi da uffici dare
giusto
alta m 16 d'armi dove come piatti a
posto non lo so e giusto io mi devo
sicilia ragazzi è quella della tattica
mica devi devi salvarti io teoricamente
ho vinto
sono morto ho vinto io per mia fattore
solare come perché questa è la modalità
dove possiamo andare in giro non è cosa
da guardare magari anche suicidato
gratis terribili cosa stato il mio dio
con quale fisica me lo stai dicendo fare
la conta sole dentro cosa sta vedendo
perché farebbe così è mille guai
caramellare grazie ai martelli mi
ammazzo formativo di questi posso
picchiarne verbo aia vado a picchiare
cane un problema gli aspetti di
picchiare il cane che portava mai non
faccio punto voglio sono o perfetto
quindi è vero hanno vinto tutti in
grillo gioco quindi hunger games angri
games giochi incavolati credo ultimo
bambino che sopravviva di che sopravvive
vince va bene con la squadra e meno era
preso già io sto pensando per non fare
la tac alcuna c'è male che male
picchiata che basta un pick up che ha
vinto ha vinto io sono in mano chi non
più forte sono allora lattante
fortissimi rispettate le regole debian
game poteri ma riesce si prende rar ma
poi si può combattere gli alimenti che
ci prendiamo le anteprime di arabella
erano belle padellate ti prego
trecento ok ma non si strugge a ok sono
uscito sono uscito ok frutta l'apertura
di qui ognuno per serie energia ho
trovato una vita dove sei non sono più
tracce aiuto ahia ahia
una vita che male male male detto però
che soprattutto in piscina perché in aa
perché non sono morto come se volessimo
io contro ferrio contro fere è perché
non ce l'abbiamo trovato in tempo non ci
sono state esatto finitivo lo spareggio
mi sa che se stati una coppia metteranno
a vincere e mi sono fiondato l'attento
menato era che viene trovato il gioco
fortissimo c'è un iceberg by sia bella
anche questa estate rimette la corrente
in casa giusto esatto periodo preghiera
quello cattivo
il bambino anzi de france si sono io il
cattivo jason della questione esatto tu
sei un po un bimbo che brutto ma qualche
brutto ma non ho capito con quale
confidenza me lo stai dicendo che
possono stare sotto gli oggetti artista
pestarmi personalissimo perdono e per è
mossa per è morta ma per monica stupido
stesso a dagli avete davvero sono un
uomo utilizzato con le gambe tipo
italiano le ho le gambe ma fa niente né
della luce dei due mentalità che fai che
per passare 18 eccoti visto e meno
tenero è possibile ma non è possibile
raga cell e sport di questo giorno ailin
sic hayden si che onesto lavoratore
dobbiamo nasco nascondino ragazzi e
nascondino con find the bay vis a vis
all'inizio io devo trovare trovo io
davvero intera io a me da uno schermo
rosso quindi per con 30 secondi
sì è vero che mi si leggono sponde rete
usciti vicino ha sentito il parere
era come se andasse così come restano
sul tema era lo so peraltro minuti solo
è il fine è quello che dirigeva dobbiamo
dividerci ma secondo me è andata nel
garage di torino io bevo acqua
sottocosto sta ridendo sta vivendo nel
garage nel grande garage di grave ha
dichiarato il garage del garage non
riuscire sono schiacciato la sola casa
hanno trovato vedo io la vedo dov'è che
sei ma dov'era la lega razza del garage
mamma mia fede si è durata un secondo
mia nonna si nasconde meglio cos'è per
lei mi raccomando spero ben bene meglio
di come li nasconde mi sa che di sopra
quante porte sento anche secondo me di
sopra versi però non lo sto provando li
odio guarda che è veramente fatta bene
st modalità e la finale la vedi tu hai
dessì che quella che vi piace di più
mamma mia ragazzi è un casino ma non c'è
tempo genesi ten 2 che ha veramente è
difficilissimo ora che è non è dove ti
sei una ski bus hai guardato in cucina
delle credenze nella credenza o per
tutto orca va bene che la doccia mannaia
allora detto cascino 50 secondi sono
sottoterra ma lei nato dove lo
scantinato fini c'è uno scantinato manco
lo sapevo ma c'era uno scappa non lo
sapevo proprio ma sì ma non c'ero stava
nel gioco originale ecco ecco come brava
brava brava brava fare penso indizi non
ce l'avreste fatta la mettiamo
adesso i bambini siamo io e fare ma che
no ma io sia giusto è sì ma time ha
chiesto di gioco e ciò ha già perso ho
già perso maledetti infami ascoltando i
vostri pasti non puoi non di qua non di
qua della portali ho sempre problemi ad
aprire le porte
sì esatto dove non è un problema quanto
manca dai 5 no dai perché ma siete
insieme e non lo dico con partito allora
so che sono scemo dell'altro e jesina
anno diventano ancora più scemi di
solito ci impegniamo allora dài mannaia
ei video nascosta la forchetta volano ti
fa niente di oggi cercato di colpire
mamma mia mamma mia ragazzi non so come
crede l'adrenalina è bellissimo ne pensa
gli elettrodomestici gli
elettrodomestici nel portone trova
erratico un ct luglio non valeva maniera
di vista all'inizio quando si è corso
via
no ero completamente dietro di te sai
partito io ero lì per lì prima messa in
partita in automatico aiuti occhi le
ripristiano corrente voi due c'è stato e
demoniaco a quello di prima dove ho
vinto io come faccio a ripristina la
corrente così la vedessero varetti il
gasolio benzina maria orror fortissimo è
diventato eccole questo non lo hanno
trovato e non si vabbè non so 16 per
cento
chi è questo ma come si fa
peccato peccato non funziona non riesco
comunque perché non riesca a rifilare il
code smettila mai malissimo ma ok
funziona ma dai ma che funziona da sisto
proprio da si stia vicino al sul buco
prince buco piuttosto esistono bene
mancassero una brava 27 stagioni di
linee di credito e giù giù giù giù a
veronica è una tanica prendiamo la
prende non aprire la prefetta piace
qualche ruota era la mia la mia nonna
paterna
l'hack è successo mi attacca la tanica
l'attaccante e una tanica spin ma ora è
una tanica horror ma avete vinto anche
se provenendo da che ci sono in squadra
a caso grazie ragazzi che hanno
partecipato questo video è stato molto
carino
fatemi sapere se volete altri episodi
anche di robot soprattutto perché robert
veramente figo e volevo farvi sapere che
se volete iscrivervi al canale trovate
il tasto sotto il video dove schiaccia
con la vicina campanellina che se
cliccata il rimanete aggiornati su tutti
video riescono ecc anche canalis tevere
in descrizione poi sempre ci vediamo il
prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]